element timeline by Horace Ranjit Kumar
first gold was found when and who is
unknown its symbol is a you it's atomic
number is 79 and atomic mass is 190 6.97
next silver was found when and who is
also unknown the symbol for silver is AG
it's atomic number is 47 atomic mass is
100 and 7.8 682 later copper was found
when and who is also unknown its symbol
is see you it's atomic number is 29 and
it's atomic mass is 63.5 46 next was
iron when and who is also unknown its
symbol as f e an atomic number is 26 and
the atomic mass is 55.8 47 sequentially
follow lead what and who is also unknown
symbol is PB atomic number is 82 and
atomic mass is 207 point to successively
followed 10 when and who is also unknown
symbol is SN atomic number is 50 and
atomic mass is 118 point seven one
directly followed by was mercury when
and who is also unknown symbol is Hg
atomic number is 80 atomic mass is 200
point five nine next was sulphur when
and who is also unknown symbol as s
atomic number is sixteen atomic mass is
thirty 2.06 next was carbon when and who
is again also unknown symbol is C atomic
number is six atomic mass is 12.0 107
later in more modern times arsenic was
found in about 1250 by Magnus its symbol
is a s atomic number is 33 an atomic
mass is 74.9 to 160 successively
followed zinc summer ended 30 century
was discovered
by who is unknown its symbol is Z in
atomic number is 30 and atomic mass is
65.4 09 next phosphorus was discovered
in 1669 by handing brand its symbol is P
atomic number is 15 and atomic mass is
30 point nine seven four later antimony
was found when is not exactly known but
it is known that it's earlier than the
17th century who is unknown its simplest
SB atomic numbers 51 and atomic mass is
120 1.75 successively cobalt was found
at about 1735 by George Brent its symbol
is co atomic number is 27 atomic mass is
58.9 33 next platinum was found by usher
in 1735 its symbol is PT atomic number
is 78 and atomic mass is 190 5.08
subsequently follow nickel it was
discovered in 1751 by constant its
symbol is n I atomic number is 28 and
atomic mass is 58.6 93 the next element
discovered was bismuth it would
discovered in 1753 by Geoffrey it
symbols bi atomic numbers 83 and atomic
mass is 208 point 98 next hydrogen was
discovered in 1766 by Cavendish it
symbols H atomic number is one atomic
mass is 1.00 78 successively nitrogen
was discovered in 1772 it would discover
2 by root 3rd 4th and the symbols n its
atomic number is seven and the top of
massive 14.00 6m after that oxygen was
discovered in 1774 by Priestley and seal
its symbols Oh atomic number is 8 and
atomic mass is 15 / mennonite next
chlorine was found in the same year by
his skill its symbol is CL atomic number
is 17 and atomic masses
075 868 to subsequently manganese was
found in the same year in 1774 by
Gannett skill and Bergman its symbol is
FN atomic number is 25 an atomic mass is
54 4.94 next molybdenum was found in
1778 place Gilligan and its symbol is mo
int atomic number is 42 and atomic mass
is 107 point 8 682 after that tellurium
was found in 1782 by region Steen its
symbol is te atomic number is 52 an
atomic mass is 120 7.6 later tungsten
was found in 1783 by JD a or and FDA
were it symbols w atomic mass number is
74 atomic mass is 180 3.84 after that
uranium was found in 1789 it was found
by Martin clapper road its symbol is you
atomic number is 92 @ comma mass is 230
8.0 289 successively titanium was found
in 1791 it was found by gregor and its
symbol is TI atomic number is 20 tube an
atomic mass is 47 48 subsequently you
Tyrion was found in 1794 by Gavilan it's
simple it's why atomic number is 39 and
todd mass is 88.9 0585 next chromium was
found in 1797 by beckylyn its symbols
see our atomic number is 24 an atomic
mass is 51.9 96 moon after that
beryllium was found in 1798 by vaseline
its symbol is be atomic numbers for an
atomic mass is 9.0 1218 to next then a
DM was found in 1801 by Del Rio its
symbol is V comma bomb number is 23 an
atomic mass is 50.9
415 successively niobium was found in
1801 by hatchet its symbol is NB a comic
number is 41 and atomic mass is 90 2.90
638 subsequently tantalum was found in
1802 by eckleburg if symbol is ta atomic
number is 73 and atomic mass is 180
point nine 479 after that cerium was
found in 1803 by Perseus his linger a
clap wrote its symbol is cee atomic
number is 58 and atomic mass is 140 /
115 next gladium was found in 1803 by
wollaston its symbol is pd atomic number
is 46 atomic mass is 100 6.42 right
after that wollaston also found rhodium
in the same year 1803 its symbol is Rh
atomic number is 45 atomic mass is 102.9
055 successively osmium was found in
1803 by tenant its symbol is OS atomic
number is 76 atomic mass is 190 point 23
subsequently iridium was found in 1803
by tenant its symbol is ir atomic number
is 77 atomic mass is 190 2.22 next
sodium was found in 1807 by devi its
symbol is na atomic number is 11 atomic
mass is 22.98 nine 768 right after that
in 1807 devi again found another element
his name was potassium symbol SK atomic
number is 19 atomic mass is 39.0 983 in
the same year 1808 strontium was found
by devi its symbol as sr atomic number
is 38 and atomic mass is 80 7.62 right
after that
day we found our element in the same
year 1808 called barium its symbol is BA
atomic number is 56 atomic mass is 130
7.3 twosome right after that David
Furner element called calcium in 1808
its symbol is ca atomic numbers 20
atomic mass is 40 point zero seven eight
right after that David found our element
in 1808 its name was magnesium its
symbol is mg atomic number is 12 atomic
mass is 24 point 30 50 the final one day
we found was called boerum it was also
an 1808 its symbol is be atomic number
is five and atomic mass is 10.8 11
successively iodine was found in 1811 by
court release its simplest I atomic
number is 53 and atomic mass is 100
26.90 447 after that lithium was found
in 1817 but ARF huetzin its symbol is Li
atomic number is three atomic mass is
6.94 one next cadmium was found in 1817
by strong mayor its symbol is CG atomic
number is 48 an atomic mass is 112 point
4 11 subsequently selenium was found
that Brazilians in 1817 its symbol is se
atomic number is 34 an atomic mass is
seventy eight point nine six
successively silicon was found at
Brazilians in 1824 its symbol is si
atomic number is 14 and atomic mass is
28.0 855 next zirconium was found very
busy days again in 1824 its symbol is Z
or atomic numbers 40 and atomic mass is
91.2 24 next Silicon was found in 1824
by Brazil use its symbol is s I atomic
number is 14 at atomic
is 28.0 855 successively bromine was
found in 1826 by ballard if Sybil is BR
atomic number is thirty-five and atomic
mass is seventy 9.90 for subsequently
aluminum was found in 1827 by roller its
symbol is al atomic number is thirteen
atomic mass is twenty 6.98 1539 after
that thorium was found in 1828 by
brasília its symbol is th atomic number
is 90 and atomic mass is 230 2.0 381
successively lanthanum was found in 1839
by moose injure its symbol this la
atomic number is 57 and atomic mass is
138 point 9055 successively Curbeam was
found in 1843 by mo centre its symbol is
TB atomic number is 65 and atomic mass
is 150 8.9 2534 next erbium was found by
mu centre in the same year 1843 its
symbol is er atomic number is 68 an
atomic mass is 160 7.26 subsequently
ruthenium was found in 1844 like loss
its symbol is are you atomic number is
44 and atomic mass is 100 1.07 after
that cesium was found in 1860 by
bouncing and kirchhoff its symbol is CS
Tomic number is 55 and atomic mass is
130 2.90 543 subsequently but Senate
kirchhoff also found rubidium in 1861
its symbol is RB atomic number is 37 and
atomic mass is eighty five point four
six seven eight next kalium was found in
one by crooks its symbol is TI atomic
number is 81 and atomic mass is two
hundred four point three eight three
three successive league indium was found
in 1863 by reach and richter this symbol
is I an atomic number is 49 and atomic
mass is 114 point 8 18 next fluorine was
discovered by mohsin in 1866 its symbol
is f atomic number is 9 and atomic mass
is 18.99 8 40 3 subsequently gallium was
found in 1875 by a boy is important its
symbol is G a atomic number is
thirty-one an atomic mass is 69.7 32
subsequently ytterbium was found in 1878
by Mark knack its symbol is YB atomic
number 70 and atomic mass is 170 3.04
after that scandium was found in 1878 by
Nielsen its symbol is SC atomic number
is 21 and atomic masses 44.95 591 next
Sam meriem was found in 1879 by boys
bodhran its symbol is SM atomic number
is 62 and atomic mass is 150 point 36
successively holmium was found in
eighteen seventy eight by delafontaine
its symbol is h 0 atomic number is 67
and atomic mass is 164 point 9 30 32
subsequently thallium was found in 1879
bike leave its symbol is TM atomic
number is 69 and atomic mass is 160 8.9
3421 next gadolinium was found in 1880
by Marlon Ignac its symbol is GG atomic
number is 64 and atomic mass is 150 7.25
successively
she'll diamond was found an 1885 by one
west buck its symbol is PR atomic number
is 59 an atomic mass is 140 point 90 765
next neodymium was found in 1885 as well
it was also discovered by the same
person one bez back its symbol is ND
atomic number is 60 an atomic mass is
140 4.24 subsequently this protein was
found in 1886 by boys bodhran its symbol
is dy atomic number is 66 atomic mass is
160 2.5 after that european was found in
1890 is found by boys bodhran its symbol
is EU atomic number is 63 atomic mass is
150 1.96 55 next hour gone was found in
1894 by Rayleigh and Ramsey its symbol
is a are atomic number is 18 and atomic
mass is 39.9 48 next helium was found in
1895 by Ramsey its symbol is 8g atomic
number is 13 and atomic mass is 4.00
2602 next germanium was found 1886 by
Winkler its symbol is GE atomic number
is 32 atomic mass is 72.6 one later
Krypton was found in 1898 by Ramsey and
Travers its symbol is kr atomic number
is 36 and atomic mass is 80 3.8 next me
animals found in 1898 by Ramsey and
Travers its symbol is n.e atomic number
is 10 and atomic mass is 20 point 17
97 after that Xena was found in 1898 by
Ramsey and Travers its symbol is XE
atomic number is 54 and atomic mass is
130 1.29 after that pauline IAM was
found in 1898 by curie its symbol is p.o
atomic number is 80 for an atomic mass
is 200 8.9 82 for successively radium
was found in 1898 by Curie its symbol is
our a atomic number is 88 and atomic
mass is 220 6.0 254 next act name was
found in 1899 by Deb beer in its symbol
is AC atomic number is 89 and atomic
mass is 220 7.0 278 subsequently radon
was found in 1900 by Dorn its symbol is
RN atomic number is 86 and atomic mass
is 220 2.0 176 after that lutetium was
found in 1907 by urbane it symbols Lu
atomic number 71 an atomic mass is 174
point nine six seven later protactinium
was found in 1913 by agent and go ring
its symbol is PA atomic numbers 91 and
atomic mass is 230 1.03 588 successively
hafnium was found in 1923 by coaster and
bone have to say its symbol as hf atomic
number 72 and atomic mass is 170 8.49
subsequently radian was found 1925 I
nodak bird and
its symbol is re atomic number is 75 an
atomic mass is 186 point 207 after that
technet team was found in 1937 my career
and segue its symbol is TC atomic number
is 43 and atomic mass is 98.9 072
shortly following was francium which was
discovered in 1939 it was discovered by
perry its symbol is fr atomic number is
87 and atomic mass is 220 3.0 197 after
that astatine was found in nineteen
forty by Corson its symbol is 80 atomic
number is 85 and atomic mass is two
hundred nine point nine eight seven one
successively neptunium was found in 1940
by Macmillan and Allison its symbol is
NP atomic number is 93 and atomic mass
is 230 7.0 482 subsequently plutonium
was found in nineteen forty by seaboard
its symbol is P new atomic number is 94
and atomic mass is 240 4.0 642 later
kiram was found in 1944 by Seaborg its
symbol is CM atomic number 96 and atomic
mass is 240 7.0 703 soon after that
americium was found in 1944 by seaworld
its symbol is am atomic number is 95 and
atomic mass is 240 3.06 14 after that to
honor mentally Mendeleev mendeley me was
found in 1955 by dorrough so Harvey
Chopin Thomson and Seaborg its symbol is
md atomic number is 101 and atomic mass
is 250 8.1 after that promethium was
found in 1945 I'm Aaron ski its symbol
is p.m. atomic number is 61 and atomic
mass is 140 4.91 27 next berkelium was
found in 1949 by seeburg its symbol is
BK atomic number is 97 and atomic mass
is 240 7.0 703 after that California was
found in 1950 by Thompson Street Durazo
and see work its symbol a CF atomic
number is 98 Tomic masses and an atomic
mass is 250 1.07 96 soon after fermium
was founded in nineteen fifty two by
Joseph its symbol is FM atomic number is
100 and atomic mass is 250 7.0 951
subsequently einsteinium was found in
1952 by Jiro so its symbol is es atomic
number is 99 and atomic mass is 254 next
nobelium was found in 1958 by jirozo
sick gland Walton and Seaborg its symbol
is an oak atomic number is 102 and
atomic mass is 259 point 100 narc
successively lawrencium was found in
1961 by zero so its symbol is lr atomic
number s103 an atomic mass is 262
subsequently with the 40m was found in
1964 by zero so its symbol is RF atomic
number is 100 for an atomic mass is 261
after that dubnium was from 1967 x 0 so
its symbol is DB atomic number is 105
and atomic mass is 262 later ciborium
was found in 1975 for x 0 so its symbol
is SG atomic number is 106 and atomic
mass is 266 successively Boreum was
found in 1975 by Armbruster its symbol
is bh atomic number is 107 and atomic
mass is 264 subsequently meet nerium was
found in 1982 by Armbruster and buzzes
umber its symbol is empty atomic number
is 109 and atomic mass is 268
successively haseen was found 1984 by
the same people Armbruster and muslim
birth its symbol as HS atomic number is
108 and atomic mass is 269 soon after
darmstadt TM was found 1994 by hoffman
and enough its symbol is d s atomic
numbers 110 and atomic mass is 281 after
that ruined jennean was found in 1994 by
hoffman and enough its symbol is RG
atomic numbers 111 and atomic mass is
280 successively nvm was found in 1996
by hoffman and in all its symbol is udb
atomic number is 112 an atomic mass is
285 the rest of the elements such as an
interior cardium underpin team on an
exam
are all temporary names for element
which I've is down below these elements
are not known it look Tomic mass symbol
and that is why not all periodic tables
have these builders finally you put
everything together you get the periodic
table